[Musique]
la maison du parc c'est effectivement le
coeur du parc naturel
donald la brenne
c'est un petit peu le passage raconte on
a beau dire quand on arrive en brenne à
l'année on a à peu près 70 mille
visiteurs mais
je dirais sur une partie du paysage
extrêmement ouvert à la fois
caractéristique est essentiel pour la
peine
[Musique]
le parc naturel de la brenne a été créée
dans les années 90 en plein coeur d'un
territoire très identifié par ses étant
très vite la maison du parc est devenu
la porte d'entrée de sa découverte par
les touristes
édifié dans un ancien domaine agricole
typiques de cette région
elle rassemble une quarantaine de
personnes qui oeuvrent à remplir toutes
les missions qui lui sont propres la
préservation environnementale bien sûr
mais aussi l'activité économique et
humaine de son territoire
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de ces
hommes et de ces femmes qui jour après
jour mettent toute leur énergie à
crayonner le diplôme pour la découverte
de la réserve
alors il me reste trois places
c'est 8 euros par personne donc ça dure
deux heures à peu près et oui vous
règlerez sur place
justin est l'une des trois permanente
qui anime l'accueil à l'entrée de la
boutique de la maison du pas c'est un
petit peu le passage incontournable on
va dire quand on arrive en brenne pour
avoir les informations sur les revenus
sur ce compte ni avoir à faire et c'est
à l'année on a à peu près 70 mille
visiteurs donc la saison aujourd'hui à
s'est allongée en fait c'est là qu'on a
à partir d'un petit peu avant pas que
jusqu'à la toussaint on a vraiment du
monde constamment on est ouvert toute
l'année donc déjà on a des demandes
aussi qui varient en fonction des
saisons
donc c'est là aussi que ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'il va rencontrer
vraiment des personnes sur fond d'aidé
monde vraiment vraiment varié nous on a
un autre travail aussi un petit peu
l'hiver puisque on a un petit peu moins
de monde on travaille sur la partie
documentation donc touristique on
prépare la saison suivante avec tout le
contact avec les prestataires et cetera
nous c'est vraiment vraiment varié en
fait en été il n'est pas rare de voir
plus de 300 personnes dans la journée
sans oublier les nombreux appels
téléphoniques ici être polyvalent est
indispensable justin tiend aussi la
pièce pour venir en aide à marica qui
gère la boutique alors arbres
je n'aime pas les passes à ses lamas
côté autrichien
je n'aime pas les passeurs vous avez
combien de producteurs dans le magasin
alors je dirais à peu près 120 à tour
des entrées sans s en va tout compris le
nombre de références je dirais plutôt à
tour dès 2002 entre 2000 et 3000 le
réassortiment effet par les producteurs
il n'y a pas de stockage autant dire
qu'il faut être vigilant et réactif pour
ne pas retrouver les étagères on sait
jamais quand la libration arif est pas
faire ça peut rêver tout en même temps
comme c'est arrivé il ya il y a des
jours où ça pue qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
pas livrer ses tarifs
comme scout c'est vraiment un petit peu
compliquées à prévoir
marica qui possède davantage de parler
plusieurs langues s'occupe également
d'accueillir les visiteurs
[Musique]
non
on ma
c'est pour les clôtures on sera comme
l'an dernier en fine réunion avec mais
l'ensemble des cinq exploitants et puis
on convoquera le prestataire pour faire
le point sur sur chacun des segments
mais c'est vrai une que cette année la
priorité c'est vraiment tout ce qui doit
se construire autour de pissotière ou de
de foucault en termes de clôture vincent
et thibaut font partie de ceux qui sur
le terrain veille au patrimoine naturel
géré par le passé étant c'est
effectivement les étangs qui sont
caractérise je dirais la richesse la
biodiversité de la brenne mais il ne
faut pas oublier les prairies puisque
dans certaines d'entre elles on peut
rencontrer plus de 80 plantes à fleurs
différentes
et quand on a une grande variété de
plantes on a évidemment une grande
variété de faune notamment d'insectes
donc toute l'activité agricole sur cette
réserve naturelle est absolument capital
au bon maintien de la biodiversité le
parc naturel régional de la brenne à
plusieurs missions dont celle de la
protection de la nature et de la
préservation de son patrimoine naturel
pour ce faire on est une équipe d'une
quinzaine d'agents avec des missions
à ces différentes mais qui se recroisent
de toute façon est une autre grande
licence c'est l'accueil du public
l'accueil du public justement thibault
aujourd'hui à son programme une
permanence à la maison de la nature la
partie du travail à la maison de la
nature ça consiste à prolonger le côté
pédagogique de la réserve où on
accueille le public
la maison de la nature ont fait
principalement de l'accueil naturaliste
pour faire découvrir la nature aux
visiteurs en brenne les oiseaux qui
l'amphibien présenter les différents
sites où ils peuvent aller observer
toutes ces espèces là sur l'année je
passe au moins la moitié de mon temps à
l'extérieur était comme hiver au chaud
comme au froid c'est c'est toujours
plaisant on voit toujours une grande
diversité au niveau des paysages en
fonction de la lumière en fonction de
l'heure et des saisons
sur ce territoire les néophytes côtoient
les ornithologues chevreul à la
recherche de l'oiseau rare
[Musique]
on ma
au parc on les appelle les gars la
brigade sont quatre ils travaillent en
équipes de deux leur mission la lutte
contre les espèces envahissantes leur
terrain de jeu les étangs du parc privé
ou public
ce matin ils partent ramasser les nas ou
espère t-il
les écrevisses rouge louisiane véritable
fléau pour le milieu aquatique se seront
fait piéger voyez tous les grappes une
femelle peut porter jusqu'à 600 e et il
peut pondre deux fois dans l'année donc
ça peut aller vraiment très très vite on
assure du piégeage sur un certain nombre
des temps tout au long de l'année donc
c'est une mission permanente donc avec
des passages réguliers au moins une à
deux fois par semaine parfois plus selon
l'anp souvent les cycles donc c'est
vraiment ça le locker le cadre de
l'émission la brigade a été constituée
en priorité pour cette espèce là n'est
pas non plus à l'abri d'en trouver sur
les routes dans les prairies dans les
fossés vraiment rien n'arrête
l'écrevisse de louisiane
elle peut parcourir des kilomètres en
plusieurs jours même en dehors de l'eau
elle résiste vraiment très très
facilement
l'équipe intervient depuis deux ans sur
cet élan avec un certain succès mais
l'équilibré reste très fragile et
dépendante des milieux alentours c'est
pourquoi les propriétaires d'étangs
peuvent faire appel à la brigade brigade
espèces exotiques envahissantes et
toujours sur le terrain donc avant
d'intervenir ou faire quoi que ce soit
ou juste pour vérifier les propriétaires
nous appelle on intervient et soit on
met en place après une action de gestion
où on leur conseille certaines choses où
on leur prête du matériel aussi ça c'est
possible
aujourd'hui aurélie et simon auront
amassé 21 une écrevisse dans les nasses
après les avoir détruites comme la loi
les y oblige
linotte soigneusement sur leurs carnets
les chiffres pour leurs statistiques
grâce à cette action en deux ans la
population d'ecroville de cet étang n'a
pas augmenté
[Musique]
a priori rien ne distingue cette salle
d'une auberge de campagne pourtant le
restaurant de la maison du parc à ses
particularités
il est géré par une association depuis
sa création il ya 23 ans
sur une des toutes seules on ne voulait
pas de
restauration traditionnelle
pour pas concurrents chez les
restaurateurs locaux et dont il m'est
venue l'idée de faire des tartines pour
présenter les produits locaux
bon là voyez je suis en train de faire
la une tartine de saison avec les
légumes légumes qui viennent du seat et
à côté avec qui on travaille voilà huit
personnes travaillent habituellement ici
un chiffre qui peut doubler pendant la
période estivale
il faut dire que l'établissement
rencontre un vrai succès sur une année
nous sommes autour à 24 milles couverts
le midi
ce qui représente à peu près 65 ouvert
par jour nous travaillons 7 jours sur 7
déjà par le jour de noël et jour de l'an
nous sommes fermés et après l'année
dernière pour 2016 nous avons fait
vingt-cinq mille crêpes qui sont servis
elle dans l'après midi comme à la
boutique la polyvalence est de mise
en contrepartie des aménagements
d'horaires et de planning and travaille
depuis 14 ans
ici c'est vrai qu'on travaille pas le
soir donc on a une qualité de vie quand
on est dans la restauration
effectivement avoir une famille
travaille en restauration travailler 12h
faire la coupure reprendre le soir c'est
assez compliqué après quand on a des
enfants
jean louis a fêté ses 18 ans de présence
il est le seul à avoir un diplôme de
serveurs avec le chef pat ici c'est
familial mais familial sauf que quand il
ya du monde
allez plus voilà là c'est que ça tourne
familiale ou pas là il ya plus de
il faut il faut les professionnels
en cuisine le chef attaqué la confection
des frites de carpes il se mange 100 kg
par semaine en été
l'automne pointe le bout de son nez en
salle les clients sont toujours nombreux
le dimanche
il est impératif de réserver en toute
saison
[Musique]
le parc naturel régional rayonne sur un
territoire qui a une forme d'homogénéité
il forme de cohérence et c'est vrai
qu'il ya un certain nombre de sujets de
thématiques qui n'étaient pas portés par
les collectivités territoriales
intermédiaire mais communes ou les
communautés de communes donc thématiques
et sujets qui ont été pris en charge
très naturellement par le parc naturel
régional de la brenne c'est vrai dans le
domaine de la santé c'est vrai dans le
domaine culturel
c'est vrai dans le domaine de la petite
enfance christelle est l'une des deux
musiciens ont employé par le parc pour
apporter aux enseignants qui en font la
demande leur expertise
c'est son point d'attaché la maison du
parc son champ d'activité s'étend sur
toutes les écoles du territoire
bonjour moi je m'appelle christen il ya
des enfants que je connais ya plein
d'enfants tu ne connais pas on s'est vu
l'année dernière je suis venu faire de
la musique avec les autres enfants qui
sont ces aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est
la rentrée pour elle dans l'école de
renaix pendant un semestre elle viendra
chaque semaine animé un atelier qui
servira de support pédagogique augmenté
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une aide parce que la
musique fait partie du programme
scolaire c'est aussi une aide de
quelqu'un de spécialisé pour les
enseignants et les enfants bien sûr mais
c'est pas une pour créer des musiciens
ce sont les élus du parc qui ont un jour
mais au programme cette animation à
destination des enfants du territoire
pour le plus grand plaisir de nous
à jamais
on n'a jamais
jamais
vingt mille fourmies à moi monté en taxi
[Musique]
la cinquantaine de parcs naturels
régionaux existants en france sont tous
différents et mènent des politiques de
territoire adaptés à leurs
particularismes
mais la brenne en prenant en compte les
besoins de sa population et
singulièrement de ces jeunes à créer une
dynamique suivi aujourd'hui par d'autres
structures en tête
[Musique]
avec cinq états
chante des chansons
[Musique]
où
au poisson
artur mas